okay back here on the rich eisen show to
talk some pucks
maybe about his major league baseball
leading san francisco giants is my
emmy nominated friend colin hanks how
you been colin i've been good rich how
about yourself
you know what i figured uh with the
montreal canadiens back
in the uh stanley cup final
for the first time since taking on your
los angeles kings back in 1993
i figured let me get you on
to tell me the story i've never i've met
a handful of people talk about this but
none as passionately as you do colin
well
everybody just google digital fireplace
and gather around
the warmth of your digital screens as i
tell
[Laughter]
but in fact is the curse of an entire
nation
everybody knows that hockey is
essentially
canada's baseball yes it is the national
past time there is
no other sport that even comes close uh
to the
uh uh uh to the uh canadian people
than the sport of hockey here's what you
need to know about
the 1993 finals because we got to look
we got to look back before we can look
forward absolutely colin
this stanley cup final that's right
not the final final
very similar distinction very important
distinction singular yes
so in 1993 there's a couple of things
that you need to remember first off the
los angeles kings had wayne gretzky
which was by far
canada's most important export
although no one wanted to export wayne
gretzky with the exception of peter
parkington the owner of the edmonton
oilers yes sir
and with wayne gretzky came a defenseman
by the name of marty mcsorley now this
guy was a bruiser this guy was
was was a was a big dude this guy wore
goalie-sized jerseys so that he could
get them
off quicker during a fight
so marty mcsorley comes to los angeles
with wayne gretzky and they play and the
kings all of a sudden become contenders
they become really great there's a
couple of really interesting
things that happen just from a
statistical kind of like
fun standpoint in 1993 in 1993 the los
angeles kings make it to their first
final
the canadians make it to their i believe
it was like their 34th
final okay there is no
organization in north american sports
that has more titles in the montreal
canadian that's correct i try new york
i know that that's the only one that
comes within even hailing distance
yes exactly right so but here's here's
the funny thing
that season was the 100th anniversary
of the stanley cup which was originally
called the dominion cup
of canada and it was named after lord
stanley who was in charge of
the dominion of canada and the los
angeles kings needed to beat
three other canadian teams in order to
get to the final
in this in the uh the the semi-final the
the western conference final
um although it wasn't the western
conference at the time
this is the days of the old uh smythe
division and whatnot yes sir
they beat the the los angeles kings beat
the toronto maple leafs
now everyone in canada literally
everyone in canada wanted
the habs versus the leafs in the final
that would have been
the most canadian thing ever to occur
in the history of canada that would have
driven
that that would have literally there
would be no more labats
to be sold there'd be no more molson
all of the canadian beer would would be
sold and everyone would be glued
glued to their sets but that didn't
happen because the los angeles kings
beat
the maple leafs and they ended up
playing in montreal for games
one and two they beat the canadians in
game
one and in game two they're going into
the final
two minutes of the game with a one goal
lead
and it's looking pretty good it's
looking like they're about to go back to
los angeles
with a two games to zero league in the
stanley cup finals that's going to be
pretty
pretty tough to beat but here's what
happens about two minutes left in the
game
the montreal coach pulls aside the
referee
and says i want to measure marty
mcsorley's stick
that's jacques de meres famous the
famous yes
now when we say measure the stick we
mean that the curvature of the blade of
the stick the
the part that actually touches the puck
there's a rule that says that there
the curvature cannot exceed a certain
measurement
and i'd never seen this before but they
pulled out some sort of weird
rudimentary device yes
that measured the curvature of marty
mcsorley stick and it turns out he was
indeed playing with an illegal stick
he goes to the sin bin for two minutes
canadians pull patrick law from the net
they have a six on four not only do they
score a goal within the final two
minutes of the game
they score another goal within the final
uh within uh uh
i believe the the opening minutes yes
the opening minute 50
some odd seconds in eric desjardins
lights the lamp
and and heart uh hearts break uh in
southern california
uh everyone rises in jubilation in
montreal in a majority of canada with
the exception of probably toronto
because they
would just want to see they had to lose
at all costs and
uh what ends up happening is montreal
ends up winning
uh all the rest of the games
they come back to los angeles they win
the next uh the next games and then they
uh they win the cup in montreal
so for years as i was growing up a
massive la kings fan
this was the curse of marty mcsorley it
was the curse of marty mcsorley stick if
he had only not played
with that curved stick maybe we would
have won the stanley cup
but but colin hanks uh it's not just
that
it's there's still to this day some
people who feel
de mer the coach of the canadienne
uh was you know it's kind of
weak to win that way i think that's what
barry melrose kind of said
first blush after the game uh in game
two
and also that he might have had some
sort of mole
within the los angeles kings locker room
to know
which sticks were in fact illegal that
it wasn't just by the eye test to see
what mcsorley was using in game one and
early in game two that they
they knew they they knew for sure that
if that was the stick chosen
it would be the one that would be
illegal that is correct i believe barry
melrose was quoted as saying
barry melrose would not have made that
call
and i'm telling you right now colin
hanks would not refer to himself in the
third person
but yes there was actually um years
later
luke robitaille who was uh one of our
hall of famers for the los
angeles kings who is still with the
organization he says that at uh at one
point a
a cop had come up to him in montreal
saying i've got to get something off my
chest you know they were measuring your
guys's sticks in between periods
before the games and in fact there were
there there was a rumor that the the
habs even went so far as to pull
the the king's stick box into their
locker room
and measure the sticks so they knew
that marty had was playing with an
illegal stick and marty actually says
there were a bunch of players that
played with illegal sticks
um so they were kind of sitting and
waiting
for the moment to to sort of pull that
card and uh
apparently uh jacques de mers uh would
have made that call
because he did colin hanks here on the
rich eisen show and to put a full button
on this as to why we're discussing this
right now prior to game one of the
stanley cup final
tonight uh between the lightning trying
to repeat
and the montreal canadien is that a
canadian team
not just montreal a canadian team has
not won the stanley cup
since that 1993 championship
that is correct and that is why actually
the curse of marty mcsorley has now
become the actual curse
of the the the dominion of canada the
nation of canada because not only has no
team won um but you know
the the the number of canadian teams
have actually go the percentage of
canadian teams i should say has gone
down within the league
in 1993 they were 33 of the league
now they're down to 23 percent of the
league and not a single one of them has
been able to win the stanley cup since
1993.
the canadian correct not the canadians
canadian so uh this might be the most
important question of this interview
colin and maybe the most important
question i've ever asked you because
it's a crucial one and it also looks
into the window of your soul
colin hanks because sagittarius and
never unfunded
outside of all that um since 1993 you've
become a well-rounded man
colin yeah you got married you have
children uh
you you have a uh terrific career acting
you've got more now than you had in
1993.
are you still rooting for the lightning
to keep this canadian curse going
colin hanks all these years later how
much spike do you have in your system
yeah because i want to say yes of course
let's keep this curse going
there there is part of me that that that
that loves that because this is
one of my favorite stories i wanted
i wanted to do a 30 for 30 about this
yes there's just something about
this all of the conspiracy theories the
ins and outs all of the simple facts
about it i find just
just completely enthralling but at the
same time
i do love canada i am an adoptive
uh son of canada i can sing o canada uh
in record time i can name almost all of
the cfl teams
i indeed love molson's and lebats
but i gotta say i think i'm rooting for
uh for the habs in this one it's only
because of
young tyler to foley former los angeles
nicely
playing for uh the canadians okay and
plus you have gone to a
grey cup final finals yeah
i mean so your your credentials are
ironclad
uh that's another 100
french canadian uh you know uh uh
uh i i i i just love canada i'm sure
they're great people anybody who says
i've seen a 55-yard line with martin
short
i think that it can can just doesn't
you've done enough that's a mic drop
that's nice
i was rooting for a rouge but i didn't
get one mm-hmm
that's a two-pointer right when you
punch something in the end zone the ball
goes in the end zone
i think so i think if someone could just
turn the digital fireplace off and
google that for me i would be
greatly appreciated colin hanks here on
the rich eisen show all right before i
let you go how about your san francisco
giants colin
i am shocked 50 wins five i am so
excited
i'm seeing them tomorrow night chavez
ravine
against the deuters okay i am
just enjoying this ride i don't know how
long it'll last but man this is uh
exciting baseball i don't know if you're
aware are you aware of what
tomorrow tuesday night is at chavez
ravine oh
it is max muncie uh
go get it out of the ocean bobblehead
night
where it it's it's him pointing at uh
pointing him at the bay where he he
landed in mccovey's cove
off of uh madison bumgarner
years ago and pointed saying go get out
of the ocean
oh that's what that's it's so you're
gonna i don't know what you're gonna do
with this bobblehead were they referring
to the three championships that we won
last decade no
no no i don't think they were nope he's
just referring to the baseball that he
had off of mad bone
baseball just that one baseball
i mean we hit him into the bay all the
time
ah so you'll be there tomorrow night
very good there tomorrow night i'll be
behind home plate i'll wave to you
richard
oh will you tug on your ear carol
burnett style or something or
like every pitch
uh and before i let you go how is the uh
the offer doing you're you're
you are in the uh show
that is about the making of the
godfather correct
there has never been a limited series
that uh men are more interested in
than the making of the godfather show
yes and
we're honestly we're actually just
starting we start we start rehearsals uh
this evening actually uh but no it i'm
really excited
you know it's it's a limited series it's
gonna be on paramount plus it's all
about the making of the godfather a film
that
uh pretty much every dad loves and
adores
um and it's gonna be it's gonna be
really fascinating dexter fletcher is an
old friend of mine from band of brothers
he's directing it uh he's a great guy
very very talented dude and we've got an
incredible cast
of people playing a really really
interesting group of characters
and it's actually a really fascinating
uh insight into the
miracles it requires to just make a
movie
never mind make a make a classic one it
should be exciting and your role
in it is what again you told me i am
playing an amalgamation of
every single person that didn't think
the godfather should be made
so you're that guy you're a compilation
of that guy i'm a compilation of
everyone said that's a horrible idea but
set it with a smile
so you know i'm on the wrong side of
history but i'm completely made up
so that's good but uh you have been
before when you were
in all those drunk histories too colin
so you're correct but this one you're
sober
you're silver this one this one i am
sober but the narrator is still drunk
which is uh
oh my gosh all right colin
uh enjoy uh chavez ravine uh
well you're on the the only 50 win team
in baseball right now are the san
francisco giants
amazing and they've uh they they're so
enjoy that and enjoy the cup and let's
chat soon
this was fun you're the best at colin
hanks
on twitter and instagram i follow him
you should as well right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here